en un suburbio al noreste de kiev sergi
está limpiando los daños después de que
un dron Ruso cayera en las calles esta
madrugada
por la noche un golpe muy duro incluso
los muebles se movieron
como ya había alerta aérea entendimos
que hubo una explosión
salía el balcón y vi cristales rotos
drones misiles y proyectiles cayeron en
toda Ucrania durante la noche las
autoridades ucranianas dijeron que 40
drones que se dirigían a kiev fueron
interceptados Aunque algunas
instalaciones energéticas resultaron
dañadas causando cortes desde octubre
los ataques rusos contra los suministros
de Electricidad y agua han sido casi
semanales mientras sus fuerzas
terrestres luchan por avanzar pero esta
tercera noche consecutiva de bombardeos
no tiene precedentes Ucrania ha
contraatacado con dureza y su ejército
Afirma haber matado a unos 400 soldados
rusos y herido a otros 300 en un ataque
contra un dormitorio militar y un
almacén de municiones en la ciudad de
makifka en el este de Ucrania ocupado
por Rusia cifras exageradas según
oficiales rusos los sistemas de defensa
aérea rusos derribaron dos cohetes como
resultado del ataque de 4 misiles con
una ojiva altamente explosiva en un
punto despliegue temporal 63 militares
rusos murieron Ucrania también ha estado
llevando a cabo sus propios ataques con
drones el último alcanzó una instalación
energética en la región de brians cerca
de la frontera ucraniana